so yesterday the Eggman called in and
the egg man says Biden will win Florida
because Trump lost his former home state
of New York his home state is now
Florida and old folks in Florida don't
like Trump and they like Biden okay that
was the Eggman yesterday here is a
different perspective with a shot across
the bow at the Eggman saying it's
actually Trump who's going to win
Florida take a listen yeah I think Trump
is gonna win in Florida and the proof is
recently we tried to get a legalization
of marijuana on the ballot and we
couldn't even get six hundred thousand
signatures to get marijuana on the
ballot and I know marijuana is way more
popular than Joe Biden is so either
there's not a lot of people that vote
democratic or the system is heavily
rigged but yeah okay so listen a
cannabis in Florida I don't think that
you can say that because they couldn't
get six hundred thousand signatures for
cannabis legalization in Florida it
means Joe Biden's going to lose and in
fact there are lots of remember Florida
has the fifth oldest population in the
country there are lots of older folks in
Florida who have no interest in seeing
marijuana legalized but they still are
on board with Joe Biden's ideas rather
than Donald Trump so my point is I don't
think we can glean anything about the
Florida presidential election because of
the failure of the cannabis signature
initiative that's my perspective right
now we have a great program coming up on
the bonus show today we are going to
talk about market manipulation in terms
of why we've seen the market do what it
is doing we will also talk about the
fear that there will be chaos if
electoral college delegates are given
free rein in the November election and
we will also talk about Paul Manafort
former Trump campaign Chairman Paul
Manafort who was going to be spending a
bunch of time in prison he is being
released to his home amid Corona
virus concerns how great for him by the
way what's happening with Michael Cohen
though we'll talk about all of those
stories and more on today's bonus show
get instant access by becoming a member
at join pakman.com